so uh hello everyone I'm Dr Abigail
heskins Dynamics co-founder and CTO and
I will present you
our walk on network anomaly detection
using transfer learning based on Autumn
Corners loss and normalization
which is a key part of Dynamics
technology and we presented last year in
acmccs
which is one of the leading conferences
on network security and AI
so
um I'm uh the co-founder CTO of cynamics
uh we are cyber security starter based
on based in Israel and Boston
um we are specifically focusing on Next
Generation Network normally detection
and
it means for the first time we're
collecting a very small network of
samples Network traffic samples from
whatever Network size and architecture
the client has and we developed
technology that is able to learn from
very small Network samples from one
percent how the 100 looks like behaves
and predicts cyber attacks long before
they hit
and this is the the
significant difference than the existing
approaches today for Network detection
response as I will touch a bit later
um I have a PhD in computer science I'm
a technion and my specialization is in
this area I need Network can normally
cyber security using machine learning
deep learning
so the challenge
networks becoming bigger and more and
more complex
um number of endpoints number of devices
the network size the num the the size of
the Metro traffic
the architecture which is becoming more
complex more complicated this messy mix
as we call it between physical Networks
switches firewalls like the old days
with the cloud creating this very
challenging Network landscape that all
the existing approaches prior to
Dynamics for network and normal
infection which are all based on
appliances Club sensors basically boxes
that are placed in the network
collecting all the traffic all the time
and
analyzing this traffic and trying to
understand what's going on in the
network now this approach was perfectly
suitable like those in years ago when
the networks were compact enough so you
could really process all the packets all
the traffic and today it's impossible no
one can do it no one can collect process
analyze all traffic all the time it's in
particle cost wise overhead wise no one
can do it and the reality without
Dynamics is to to buy some appliances to
put them in strategic points in your
network which is a key child for itself
and living the majority of the network
which could be like 90 according to
surveys and reports 90 of the network as
one big blind spot with no coverage no
visibility and essentially no detection
of threats attacks bad things that's
happening and this is solved in cynamics
with this sampling based approach that I
mentioned uh before who will discuss in
this this talk because for the first
time we collect small samples but from
the entire network we we don't leave any
part of the network as a blind spot
anymore and we use this unique
technology that we developed which
enabled us for the first time to learn
from the samples on the full Network and
this is the the key Technologies we
developed in Dynamics and in this talk I
will touch upon one one of these
Technologies
so sampling
um what we see in this slide is a
breakdown of four different
data inputs Technologies in network
anomaly detection okay it's starting
with DCP dumps collecting all the
buckets all the time what I mentioned
before of course lots of data lots of
details on the network which is very
good but it's just in particle and it
requires High impractical memory and
processing overheads and even for for
small medium-sized networks it's
becoming impractical to to process
anymore so this is the PCP dumps then
the second the second technology that
you see here is SLP which is one of the
ancient Protocols of networking and it's
really always deployed protocol whatever
Network whatever gateways you're using
and it has very low network coverage
which is great but from the other hand
SNMP has a very high level volume only
volumetric information on the network
number of bits number of packets and
that's it it's it's not enough for
anything Irrelevant in today's
sophisticated threat landscape and in
order to to understand
more more challenging attacks and
threats than just volumetric attacks
the third technology is IP flows and the
IP flows means summarizations of the
entire traffic it's uh flow
summonization but again it's the entire
traffic 100 of the traffic so it's good
trade-off between SN and PCP does but
it's It suffers from from the same issue
sdcp dumps as I just discussed it in the
previous slide because it still implies
in particle overhead on
forces thing collecting analyzing all
these IQ Flows In even moderate size
networks these days and finally samples
this is what we are doing what we're
dealing with at cynamics it means
summarizations but only of samples of
the traffic right one percent for
example of the packets are being simple
and summarized and this is the the data
input that we are working with so
the advantages uh that these samples are
really applicable for the first time no
matter what's the rate of size no matter
how the network is complex or
complicated
the samples can be collected from from
such an environment and using our
Technologies we have the ability to
learn from these temples to infer from
them on the full Network which is of
course a significant chance for itself
and this is the key barrier that that
Dynamics says compared to the existing
approaches but and but but again for the
it provides us the ability to to cover
the entire network for the first time
and of course lower processing cost
because of the samples no privacy issue
which is becoming more and more
important as you can imagine and it is
due to the fact that the network samples
are only the IP headers only the
metadata of the network no payload no
application the actual sensitive and
private information is not part of this
sample so the client is can be very very
calm that no no data no private data is
ever going to be collected processed
analyzed outside which is of course very
important and finally
it's a standard built-in approach every
kind of Gateway physical virtual Legacy
or cloud is supporting at least one
standard assembly protocol it's always
there and it makes the life the life of
our clients very very simple because
they don't need to prepare anything in
advance they can just get ahead
connectors Dynamics start to send the
samples and start and get this full
coverage and for detection immediately
afterwards
this is a very high level architecture
of the solution so in the left hand side
you see this client Network and again it
doesn't matter what's the size of the
network from a very small size to the
largest Enterprises out there we're
working with all of them all of the
spectrum and no matter how the network
is built what is the architecture what
is the environment how messy between
physical networks Cloud networks
everything supporting at least one of
these standard semic protocols as I
mentioned which allows us to collect the
samples into our cloud and learn from
them about the full Network
so the big problem of course how to
learn from this one percent of network
samples on the full Network
and specifically to this talk how to
detect cyber attacks from just one
percent samples right and of course in
any kind of of application
um inferring from samples is challenging
but I think that in the network security
space it's even more challenging because
the the distribution of computer
networks is very challenging it's very
diff it's much different than the new
uniform distribution the majority of
flows are very small and only
um very small function of the flows of
the internet traffic is what we call the
elephant flows you know the Google
Communications the communications with
the largest providers out there so
um any any naive estimation
um from this one percent just multiply
by 100 by the centigrade in order to
grasp some understanding of the full the
full
um data will derive hundreds of L
percentages and will not work so and and
this is the the key behind our
Technologies because it's a very
challenging problem and I will discuss
now on uh one part of it of regarding to
detection of attacks
so the main contributions of this walk
um the the problem of course anomaly
detection in computer networks what's
new is
um the the concept that we invented here
is auto encoder losses transfer learning
and I will touch upon upon it in the
next slide
the the method is consisting of two main
steps the first is normalization of
autoencoders losses of different plants
different Networks the normalization of
the losses to uh domain environment
distribution which enable us essentially
to to forward this normalized losses to
a single Global detector that is able to
work on different networks even though
they are very different one from the
other in the sizes in the applications
in the top talkers everything and this
globalization is the key the key
invention here the fact that we are
taking the author for the losses and
instead of considering each losses in in
the old context as the classical
approaches for normal detection based on
Earth and it will recall it in the next
slide I think instead of this we are
actually
normalizing these losses of the very
different networks in the normalization
for takes us from very different spaces
the row spaces of the losses to this
single space which Compares Apple to
Apple between different clients
different networks and provides us with
this device for learning because the
global detector
is able to walk on on the different
losses due to the normalization and
become better and and
um and X more X better expert in a
normal detection with each new network
that we see with each new adapter to
simulate and this is the the key behind
this approach and of course why we do it
so first samples
um in order to
to solve this this challenging
um context of working with only sample
data and the the second reason is that
this normalization enables us to use the
same Global models on all the networks
out there because an organization
because of the transformation from the
row spaces to the normalized space to
this domain environment distribution we
can use
eventually the same detector in a
generalized way on different networks
which is
um very important because we don't need
to train a new detector from scratch for
which a new client that we see I will
this answer questions at the end
okay let's start with a quick recall on
auto encoders for anomaly detection so I
I believe most of you have used auto
encoders
um in the past for anomaly detections
whether in computer networks or other
domains and it's indeed very very easy
to use I would say approach and quite
straightforward and the the idea here is
to train Auto encoder to reconstruct the
input by forcing them to to to to learn
the patterns of the data
um such that it will be able to
reconstruct the input from this Loosely
representation which we we're creating
in this battle in a clear right we are
reducing the the dimension of the data
and by doing so we
we reducing the the information that we
have on the input and forcing go to
encoder to to understand patterns in the
underlying data that it will be able to
utilize in order to reconstruct the the
input
um even though of this Loosely
information
um due to the bottleneck and after we're
training Delta encoder the the approach
is just to to look on the on the losses
right to calculate the losses the
difference between their predictions and
the actual input and to to detect and
Analysis if this loss is too high right
because our assumption is that normal
data which is similar in its in its
characteristics to the distribution of
the data that was used for the training
um will be
will be I will be reconstructed uh quite
uh quite well by trying to encoder right
so the loss will be quite low and In
from from the other hand
um in a normally input which is very
different and the distribution of the of
the training data will derive
High loss and this is like the the most
straightforward
um approach for using utilizer models
for animal detection now this approach
has two main issues the first is that we
need to train from scratch another
encoder for each and every in our case
Network or in other applications
whatever it will be and it means that we
need to collect lots of data
to train the data encoder from scratch
to fine tune it to customize it
perhaps to improve it on the way in
order to prevent false alarms and in
order to improve its accuracy and it
means a long tedious
project until we have this Auto encoder
ready to go and until we start to
provide beneficial
insights for the client or whoever it
will be this is the first issue now the
second issue is that after we we have
done with all these long tedious project
we need to start from scratch for the
next client for the client afterwards we
we don't have any
um Head Start that we can utilize and
any knowledge that we can utilize or
take advantage of going from one client
to another
and both of these issues are actually
being solved by being addressed by our
approach because
due to the normalization
as I just mentioned before and we will
now discuss it we actually coming
pre-trained we're coming with these
Global models free training for each and
new client that we see we don't need to
train from scratch then the whole the
whole models um and and
um wait for a long time before we start
to provide value for the client from the
one hand and from the other hand we can
utilize Knowledge from one client to
another because the global models can be
in full can
can get better from each new client that
we see
this is exactly the motivation behind
our approach so um transfer learning
of the normalized doses from one client
to another
and the high level method is the net of
data is our input
we are running the first autoencoder
which is which has is its loss is being
normalized the normalized loss is being
forwarded to a global detector model
and This Global detector model is being
employed on all the networks out there
so we have this the same the single
Global detector which we are utilizing
for all networks so we can't pre-train
This Global detector is coming with us
for each new client of course it's
becoming better and it's improved along
the way this is the transfer learning
the utilization of Knowledge from one
client to another from one attack to
another but the the key thing here is
that it's a global it's a single model
that is already ready to go with each
new client that we see so we don't have
this long time to Value as in the
vanilla out and call the approach so we
have the global detector which
detects the anomaly yes or no and if
there is an anomaly being detected we
run an equivalent uh pipeline also
consisting of another autoencoder with
different architecture at different
feature base
um that we will discuss in a moment and
it's no it's lost it's also been
normalized and then we have this Global
classifier which is getting into action
in order to classify the threat the
attack what are the details what is the
attack type Etc
thank you
so the the differences compared to
previous work related work in this
domain is
um first the previous walk hasn't
studied the sample setting like ours
um it was focusing on a context where
all the data is given which as we
discussed it's becoming impractical two
days
it's uh still even though it's becoming
impractical in the real world it's still
being the the main
um context the main setting in the in
the academy
um prior to this walk second the normal
detection was made from scratch for each
for each new client we trained this
detection models the auto encoder for
example from scratch for each a new
client unlike our approach which is
using the utilizing the same Global
detector for all the clients and and
third the transfer learning the fact
that we can for the first time we can
utilize Knowledge from one client to
another
due to this normalization
okay
um a few words about the the input
so this is a flow okay this is a sample
flow flow is is another name for
connection it is just uh five uh darker
um The Source IP the destination IP the
sourceful the dashboard and the protocol
this is the five double
um the most basic ID of the network
communication
of course it has some time because it
has some number of buckets of a number
of bits that was transmitted over this
connection and this is the most basic
um connection information and I I told
you before that we the the sample the
sample protocols doesn't do not include
do not consist of the the payload itself
of the on the application the the data
itself it was sent right
um and I told it mainly an advantage
because it means that no sensitive and
private information is ever living the
the client premise so instead we we need
to to architect some features that will
provide us insights on the network
patterns so for example you can see here
some examples of such features for
example analyzing the the flow
distribution the number of flows with
one packet with two packets with three
packets Etc or another one is the
distribution of new flows means compared
to the previous time window if we
splitting our world for uh as a sliding
window of let's say aggregations of few
seconds interval H okay so we can
discuss about how much how many of the
flows in the coil window are the same as
the previous window is the window before
them Etc and such kind of manipulations
actually
as as we showcased in this walk giving a
lot of information on the patterns in
the underlying data in the network and
and when associ when a companion with
with this approach with this um loss
normalization are able to detect attacks
um very accurately as I will show you
so this is the method okay we have the
data in this uh sliding window fashion
each window is consisting of
aggregations of some few seconds
interval with the features similarly to
the two examples I showed you before the
distribution of flows new flows Etc
and this this sliding window is fed into
the Autumn called the daughter encoder
itself is
um
basically a vanilla Auto encoder in its
architecture the the key difference is
of course the what's going up what's
coming after encoder the normalization
which is normalizing the loss from the
different distribution which is affected
by the network type the network size uh
of course smaller networks will have
basically lower values of losses the no
of the normal data
um
compared to like more volatile networks
with more changes among them and this is
being covered by the normalization that
was that is added at the end after the
Autumn quarter and this normally
normalized loss is then being forwarded
to the global detector which is able to
detect if there is anomaly or not
the normalization itself
is actually being done by different
normalization metrics
um for example we found that mean Max is
is very good for
for one kind of uh of of our problems
and
um that Norm normalization is very good
for another one
um and of course there are more details
in the paper that we published it's open
for all
and regarding the the features
themselves so I show I told you in the
beginning
um about the two equivalents or very
similar pipelines right the pipeline of
the anomaly detection the pipeline of
the annual classification I told you
that both of them are based on Auto on
similar approach or the encoder
normalization and then either then the
global detector or the global classifier
and we found out that different features
base and different normalization types
of but are best suited for each one of
these pipelines so for example the aev1
which is the Autumn folder for the first
part for the the tech for the anomaly
detection we found out that using Global
features which are
which are mainly looking on on General
patterns of the data very similarly to
the example they showed you
um before like the distribution of new
flows distribution of safe flows
distribution flows themselves these
features were found out to be
um very good in detecting anomaly
um in creating this uh High trade-off
between accuracy and high accuracy and
low false false alarms and afterwards
after the the dot encoder one was
detecting anomaly we have the the second
the second pipeline which is which is uh
much more local much more robust much
more descriptive and it's its purpose is
actually to provide us details about the
the anomaly and in this pattern we use
much more descriptive features such as
about the ports the protocols the top
tokens in order to give us better
details on on the anomaly it was
detected
so um the the global model which I told
you um for example feed forward neural
network getting the normalized losses of
different devices in the network and
um using these normalized losses to
detect anomaly or not
and this is the summary combining
everything all together with the inputs
the autoencoder the normalization and
the global models
oh okay
okay some simulation study so the first
thing I wanted to show is that the
normalization is indeed effective that
it's able to transform us from low
different spaces to this domain value
distribution and we took different
clients
um four of our clients with the most
varied
Behavior one of the other besides the
architecture and we showed that in we
use the column of course you know the ks
test to show that before normalization
the distributions are very different one
for the other
um and after the normalization indeed we
are getting into this similar
distribution the the ks stats are over
005 which means we cannot reject the now
hypothesis and it means that they have a
similar statistical distribution so it
was a first demonstration of the similar
distribution afterwards we simulate did
this environment where we we use data
sets from the University of New
Brunswick in Canada and we took
different data sets it's a very good
data set for this purpose because
um each one of the data sets is very
consists of a different network
different architecture different
behaviors so it's a very good for our
use case of showing this learning from
for new from different clients one to
the other and we also implemented kitson
which is a recent state-of-the-art
approach which is based on the
traditional of encoders method
and we compared both of the
our approach and kitson you can see here
it starts with like twice as good as
position recall and uh mainly F1 score
combining both together of our approach
compared to kickson here in the left
hand side you can see
um something which is very interesting I
think this is the transfer learning in
action you can see that
I will normalized approach being trained
only on one data set is of course
providing better results than Titan but
then when we add another data set when
we train our approach on two different
data sets it's actually improving the F1
score by from all 45 to all 55 and this
is what we this is exactly what I told
you before how we utilizing this
knowledge from different networks of
different clients from each new
detection that we see because of the
normalization
um Apple to Apple
um
consequences
and of course more results that you can
see and another thing which is important
to emphasize is that
our our approach because of the siding
window uh fashion of it is also able to
predict facts before they hit so in many
cases if we
um just analyze it from from the recall
Precision metrics it's uh quite hardest
hard
um
overestimation of the actual accuracy of
our approach because many of the
detections are actually preceding the
attack themselves because
um of the analyzing of the patterns
preceding the the attack or the threat
itself so
um the the results the accuracy is much
better in reality than even then the
results I showed you before
Okay so
I'm really close
um to to the finish here
um adversarial attacks this is becoming
very interesting topic in in the past
mainly academic pure academical
um discussion but today's with the AI
based attacks it's becoming very
important to understand how much the
solution is able to cope against
such AI the serial attacker and I think
that we we clearly understand that
sampling is one of the most significant
ability encounter measures that we can
have against such an attacker because of
the
um Randomness that is being added
by definition to to the to the solution
right the attacker cannot know what
packets will be sampled and what will
not be simple and not only this the
attacker cannot know
um what is the low loss and what is the
normalization that was being used by our
Solutions so it has no idea
um in action about
our model and um the the serial
robustness is very strong in such case
so I presented you this new concept of
Auto encoders loss of normalization
um in transfer learning two of the two
steps the normalization and then the
forwarding to a global detection model
and Global classification model and we
discussed about the advantages of the
sampling in the global approaches and I
I went I went quite briefly on the
simulation but of course you can see all
more details and also about the
implementation in our paper
and before opening for questions of
course we are hiring
um all all different uh rules
specifically data scientists ml
developer developers Etc and of course
you can feel free to reach out to me
directly in this email
um about this or anything else so um
thank you very much and I'm open for any
questions
[Applause]
why is Mark the Decker can't just sit on
the detector and analyze the network
traffic patterns and you and a line is a
text with the traffic pattern so you
won't see any major change in the global
before
so you mean in Attack
u.su the attacker will be able to have
full coverage of the entire network and
not manipulate it to sit on the traffic
points that he wants to save on and
analyze the traffic from these parts and
a line is attacked with the traffic
points so you won't see a massive change
in the number of packets or you will
only stand to Google when he knows that
other will send him to Google something
like that what prevents the global
detector form
how did the global digital consider this
thing so the global detector is getting
the normalized losses from different
gateways in the network so
um in order for for sale attacker to
have enough
significant effect on the global
detector it needs to to have a
significant footprint in many of these
key gateways in the network so
um which is becoming equivalent to
having manipulating
um the majority of the network
it's um like I believe a very
um a very significant assumption
if another related question what is
detective only needs when very few steps
in order to do some feel pretty
significant okay so this is from a
different uh different question so this
is very very good question actually
because
um the thing is that cyber attacks are
not just a singular event okay it's not
just one packet out of the blue that is
happening it's actually a flow of
different of different uh steps okay you
have the infection into the network of
the penetration you have the the lateral
movement the propagation internally you
have this hip lives you have the lounge
it's a it's a quite a process so it's
not just one bucket that we sampled or
not sampled then in this process because
our approach is able to cover the entire
network for the first time we have much
more places to intervene and predict the
attack in the making actually compared
to existing opposite of course that
becoming really a likelihood question
that haven't the attack went through
them yes no Etc
[Applause]